these are the unwanted for dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health
whooping whooping cough dippy diphtheria
Roly polio I'm the monkey lockjaw this
is his story an accident I think she
scratched herself another victim for me
is that Clark
like many others is contaminated really
doctor it's nothing it's just a little
scratch
have you been protected from lockjaw why
Yes Doctor
my basic immunizations and I had a
booster about four years ago fine
another booster at this time should give
you adequate protection where will lucky
lockjaw strike next
anywhere protect your family take a tip
from Emmy immunity
in size protection can be yours when you
immunize
these are the unwanted or dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health we'll
be hoping con la que la Roly polio and
dippy diphtheria oh this is her story
it's I'm an infectious character I think
I'll find me a group to mingle with a
school bus full of children I'll wait
here till it arrives it then will dippy
diphtheria reach this group let's see
what will happen oh yeah have a group
protected by immunization where does she
go from here anywhere protect your
family
take a tip from any immunity every agent
I've protection can be yours when you
immunize
these are the unwanted for dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health dippy
diphtheria loopy hoping lucky dogs
and Roly polio let's see how he works he
searches for an innocent child to infect
poopy whooping cough looks for an
opportunity such as this while dippy
diphtheria watches for another group to
infect accidents are what locky lockjaw
thrives on protection from these
diseases is simple immunize this baby is
protected from polio these children from
whooping cough this group from
diphtheria and this young lady from
lockjaw protect your family take a tip
from any immunity protection can be
yours when you immunize
these are the unwanted for dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health who
pee whooping cough
dippy diphtheria Oh locky lockjaw and
Roly polio this is his story
on a quiet street in a peaceful town
Roly approaches his intended victim hold
it will this villain score will Roly
polio infect this innocent child let's
find out
Roly polio is forced to retreat again
where does he go from here anywhere
protect your family
take a tip from any immunity every agent
protection can be yours when you in
these are the unwanted or dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health dippy
diphtheria Roly polio locky lockjaw and
Opie whooping cough this is his story
what a perfect day for infecting a
nursery school filled with little
children from this angle I can infect
six of them from here I can infect twice
as many hold everything will Hoopoe
whooping cough infect this group of
innocent children will soon find out
where does whooping whooping cough go
from here anywhere protect your family
take a tip from any immunity keep your
family every eight inside
protection can be yours when you
immunize
beware destroy good health is our dirty
place my sarong right arm beware of
these diseases if we react Oh wonderful
whooping cough and polio every agent
sighs protection can be yours when you
immunize
these are the unwanted for dangerous
characters dedicated to bad health
whooping whooping cough dipping in
Nereus locky lockjaw and Roly polio this
new family moved into the neighborhood
oh boy oh boy as a baby hasn't had his
basic immunizations and the rest of the
family haven't had their boosters here's
a whole family we can infect who at one
fell swoop
little does Roly polio know that today
the family is completing the protection
they need here they come now
immunized now